we're here in the Willamette Valley on
Dickman farms and we're at the
Confluence of a couple of fields it's an
excellent opportunity to talk about crop
optionality so if you look to my left we
have a field of tall fescue this is a
grass seed so all of this will be
separated and all of that material will
turn into the type of grass seeds you
buy at Ace Hardware over here we have a
wheat field so this is all growing wheat
and then behind me you have a series of
onions so when you think about crop
optionality functionally you want to
rotate between the type of crops you
have on a single field when you have
several Fields next to each other this
provides an excellent opportunity to
move from one crop to another and manage
that all in one area so rotating between
drops on an annual basis allows you to
then resist that buildup of both disease
pressure as well as pest pressure